[Music]
good evening I'm Alexander oz and the
executive director here at Long now one
of the things I wanted to talk to you a
little bit about tonight is our new
newsletter that some of you members may
have seen how many people are members
here awesome thank you how many people
are guests of members here oh nice you
guys should all become members the the
newsletter has been put together by by
our staff and particularly Achmed who
had written for our blogs quite a bit
some we have an Achmed fan group but
what we're trying to do is bring some of
the the other projects around long term
thinking from around the world as well
as some of our own content together in a
place where where we also do in some
cases some original writing and and and
bring some content and a focus around
long term thinking to that content to
you so hopefully if you are a member you
have already seen it and we're working
on bringing that to an even broader
audience as we go as many of you know
before these talks we usually start them
with a long short a short film about
long term thinking and this one was
actually found for us by our
videographer chris baldwin and i think
you'll see that it it brings a new
vantage point to something that you've
seen before but also then pushes that
through time enjoy
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
not your average rekt with Bertil coffee
table so it's in the top to 10,000 year
time frame 10,000 years packed inside of
the years forward
seems like a long time and we finally
did we keep finding or getting the kind
of framing that we want from
astronomical time things that happen at
planetary pays commentary pace eclipse
pace and last month Carolyn Porco was
here talking about life nearby in the
solar system assuming the star the Sun
is not itself alive which hasn't been
determined went away to the other again
there's a book called the Star Maker by
Olaf Stapleton which raises interesting
questions she was focused on Enceladus
one of the moons of of Saturn that makes
plumes coming out of what looks like
underwater ocean that who knows she was
hoping we could put a lander there and
it might be raining microbes which might
be our kind of life or different kind of
life pretty primitive not entirely a
certainty yet so is there any place in
the solar system that we know has life
and what's going on with it
ask an astrobiologist our speaker David
Grinspoon
all right thank you so much it's really
a pleasure to be here thank you all for
coming out this evening among many other
things it's always great to be back in
San Francisco I actually lived here many
years ago when I was a postdoc down at
NASA Ames and I always avail myself of
any excuse to come back so thank you the
approach that I am taking to our
existence here to humanity on earth
comes from my field of astrobiology and
you may think that's a little weird
because astrobiologists think about life
elsewhere right that's true but it also
I think gives us a perspective on our
home planet
the uh-huh the the specific project that
I'm going to expound upon a little bit
this evening the Opera came to me as an
opportunity because I saw this ad a few
years ago for a new job position that
had been created at the Library of
Congress called the chair of
astrobiology and they were looking
specifically for somebody to undertake
research at the intersection between
astrobiology and the humanities and I
saw that ad NASA thought wow maybe this
could be the opportunity to to write
that book that I've been wanting to
write for the last decade but haven't
been able to fit into my my career as a
mid-career scientist you get too busy to
do really interesting things but but
anyway so I applied and I was very
gratified to be selected as the
inaugural chair of astrobiology at the
Library of Congress and my project was
this the title of my proposal was
astrobiology and the Anthropocene era
exploring the potential roles of life
and intelligence on earth and beyond so
you've you've heard this term the
Anthropocene or the anthropic
seen as our British colleagues say or
the Anthropocene is one of there's many
debates about what including how do you
pronounce the darn thing but the idea is
that we've entered a new geological
stage defined by this new force changing
the planet humanity it's a contentious
idea because on one hand it seems very
self aggrandizing an egotistical why
should we name a geological age after
ourselves on the other hand you could
look at it as an acknowledgment of
responsibility if we just look at the
numbers of how the the carbon cycle the
hydrological cycle the climate the land
surface all these physical aspects of
our planet are being changed rapidly by
this new force and that's us so I think
that to me the concept has a lot of
merit and I thought as someone who
studies planetary change having mostly
focused on other planets wouldn't it be
interesting to apply that perspective in
those same techniques to look at this
transition that's happening on earth now
through the lens of astrobiology so that
that was that project and it led several
years later to this book that came out
earlier this year earth in human hands
and this evening I'd like to share with
you a few of the ideas that that wound
up in that book as a result of that
project so I get the hang of this
clicker thing here is the history of the
universe on one page
you know the compression ratio is rather
large you have to leave out a few of the
details but the story of cosmic
evolution this is our attempt to to tell
the story of the universe with a focus
specifically on the major transitions
that matter and energy have gone through
from the moment of the Big Bang and the
upper left to what we so proudly call
civilization on the lower right with the
the the question marks in the arrow
suggesting that there's no reason to
think that this is
this is the end of the story this is a
stage in the story this is also being
called big history now by historians
it's basically the same thing
astronomers call it cosmic evolution and
they do a really good job with the
beginning of the story and a lousy job
with the end of the story whereas the
historians call it big history and they
do a great job with the end of the story
and a lousy job with the beginning of
the story but we're basically all
telling the same story and so it goes
from and the starting the upper left the
big bang and that makes galaxies and in
atoms which which form into galaxies and
then within galaxies you have molecular
clouds that collapse into stars and if
you look at the sort of magnifying glass
that's what's happening on the micro
scale where you've got elements and they
form into simple organic molecules and
then complex organic molecules and
around some stars planets form and on
the surface of at least one planet that
we know of that chemistry did something
really interesting became
self-replicating which led to the
possibility of Darwinian evolution and
you have life and then at least one
planet it kept going to some some
interesting phenomena we call complex
life and part of what we're trying to do
the overall project if you will of
astrobiology is to understand how
universal these later stages may be
we've learned through the techniques of
astronomy astrophysics
that the those earlier stages everything
on the left side of that page really is
universal everywhere in the universe
there's galaxies there's stars and then
the big one of the big intellectual
revolutions of our time the exoplanet
revolution has allowed us to learn that
this next stage the top right the
formation of planets is in fact also
universal we didn't know that back when
I was a postdoc here at NASA Ames in the
early 1990s it's this is recent and
profound knowledge then now we know that
every star in the sky when you look up
at a night sky basically every star has
planets so that phenomena
of planet formation has moved from this
speculative column of well we think it
ought to be universal because this
location seems normal why shouldn't
there be planets everywhere has moved
from that column to the verified we know
it's universal and if anything with
astrobiology we're trying to do that
with these later stages can we move them
from the column where at where biology
is now well it seems like it should be
universal there's nothing we know of
here that seems so unique that that
shouldn't be happening lots of places
but we haven't yet found the evidence so
that's sort of the overall point of
astrobiology now we come to our own
planet and let's look at it just for a
second if we can from the perspective of
an alien astrobiologist imagine that you
were some very patient alien species
with a long attention span watching our
planet for say you know the last few
hundred million or the last few billion
years and what would you have noticed
you would have certainly seen a lot
changing on the planet over that time
the other sort of morphing jigsaw puzzle
of the continents drifting around
coalescing and breaking apart with
continental drift the rhythmic pulsing
of the climates the ice ages the the
polar caps shrinking and expanding and
shrinking and expanding over many tens
of thousands of years but over all that
time the Nightside would have just been
pretty much an unbroken black maybe
there's the occasional lightning flash
splash of Aurora and then about four
hundred million years ago when the
continents became forested you would
have seen the occasional forest fire but
other than that the Nightside would have
been an unbroken black all those
billions of years until just very
recently boom what's this there's
definitely something new and something
very strange going on on this planet so
how can we characterize that
the one way we think about deep time of
course you've seen this is the
geological time scale this is a cartoon
form of it and over on the right side
these epochs these are the one of the
smaller ways that we break up time and
the Anthropocene has been proposed as a
new epoch to follow the Holocene which
we've been in more or less since the
last ice age and it's okay if you can't
read all the fine print on the right
there in a way that's sort of the point
that those those epochs come and go
they're not from the Earth's point of
view they're not that big a deal
they represent fluctuations in sea level
minor extinction events change in
climate but they but really epochs come
and go all the time but as you go over
to the left side of that chart you get
into larger and larger demarcations of
time and all the way over on the left
you see the eons the eons are the the
really profound transitions in Earth
history are the eon boundaries there
have only been four of them so far
one thing I proposed in my book and I'll
come back to this a little bit later is
that we may be seeing not just a epoch
boundary with the Anthropocene but
something much more profound the
beginning of a new Aeon now why would I
say that these eons represent major
transitions in earth history where
before and after Earth was a completely
different planet and each one of them is
a transition in the relationship between
life and the planet so for for instance
the Hadean on the bottom there that
literally means hellish and you would
not have wanted to be alive on the
planet then there there there was no
life because it was all asteroid impacts
and volcanoes and steam and magma and
then the Archaean at four billion years
ago is more or less that boundaries more
of us the origin of life and the
planetary environment is sort of
stabilized and calm down to the
where where you could have continuous
life and then and by the way I'm really
simplifying so if there's any geologists
in the audience don't help me with
objects please but the boundary between
the Archaean and the Proterozoic at
two-and-a-half million years ago I think
of that as when life took over the
planet chemically it's closely
associated what with what we call the
the great oxygenation event or the
oxygen sometimes called the oxygen
catastrophe I'll get back to that as
well when life filled up the atmosphere
with oxygen to the point where it was
actually a poison and wiped out a lot of
other life but that was when life sort
of chemically took over the planet and
deeply impregnated itself into the
chemical and physical workings of the
planet moving on to the the Proterozoic
phanerozoic boundary that's when that's
the origin of animal and plant life when
life got big and complex and
multicellular and then that's supposedly
it the phanerozoic is where we are
although I proposed and I'll come back
to this that potentially we're at an eon
boundary now with an equally profound
transition in the relationship between
life and the planet the moment where
cognitive processes become planetary
processes there have been many forms of
life that have changed the planet but
there has never before been a geological
force aware of its own existence and to
me that's a very profound change I'll
come back to that thought oh but the
other thing I wanted to say is that as
an astrobiologist these eon boundaries
are interesting because we're interested
in the universals of planetary evolution
and biological evolution and all these
little demarcations on the right of
epochs and periods they're not going to
match up with what we find on other
planets there's not going to be a
Jurassic
on another planet or a Holocene because
the rent evolution is too random they're
not going to be dinosaurs and people and
other planets there may be organisms
with some of the characteristics that
play some of those functions but these
eon boundaries on the left as an
astrobiologist I could imagine looking
for those on other planets an origin of
life even an oxygenation event because
photosynthesis is such an obvious
innovation I do expect to find on
another planets multicellular life and
this question of the safety of zoic
could you have cognitive life become
part of planetary functioning to me
these are all transitions that are of
astrobiological
significance potentially that you could
potentially find and map into the the
story of other planets so the local
story here began about four-and-a-half
billion years ago with the origin of the
planets in our solar system through a
process that we call accretion basically
when the Sun was born it was surrounded
by a disc of gas and dust that was
congealing and coalescing as it cooled
it was radiating energy into space and
cooling which caused it to snow not just
water ice snow but little snowballs of
rock and metal and I different kinds of
ices depending on how far it was from
the Sun and then those snowballs sort of
started to congeal and collide and
coalesce into larger pieces and the
collisions became more and more violent
and the chunks became larger and started
to gravitationally yank each other
around and at the end of that process of
accretion there were a few survivors and
those were the that was the beginning of
the planets as we know them today and
then a lot happened I'm gonna
fast-forward and skip a few crucial
steps but here we see ourselves on this
one planet where as I mentioned earlier
it suddenly lit up and if you were this
alien watching this planet this
switching on of the of the nighttime
lights would correlate with all these
other changes
changes in the atmosphere changes in the
land surface and even very recently in
just the last 60 70 years just a blink
of an eye in the life of the planet
another very strange kind of behavior
started which is that little bits of
that planet started springing back up
into space from whence at one time it
all fell down this is what I call the
curious anti accretion curious in two
senses it's it's a weird thing for a
planet to do suddenly have bits of
itself so I'll start flying back into
space and buzzing around and zooming off
to the other planets but also the
hallmark of the Advent the arrival of a
certain kind of curiosity here on earth
technologically enabled curiosity going
out to the other planets seeing what's
there radioing home the information that
these little robot emissaries find and
of course surrounding our own planet
with this this mycelium of detectors and
communicating transmitters our planet
started to self observe and to observe
the neighbors and go out in search of
answers in search of its own history and
largely that's what I've been involved
in for my career as a planetary
scientist is modeling the histories of
other planets and I've been fortunate to
be part of a few teams of people that
have proposed and built and flown
spacecraft to other planets to learn
things about climate history and
catastrophic change on planets that's
sort of sort of my day job and one thing
we've learned through this exercise of
comparative planetology is that the
rocky planets earth and venus and mars
and now we're starting to learn a little
bit about the rocky planets just just
beginning to really ask questions about
the rocky planets around other stars but
they seem to have similar origins and
early environments
what we've learned about early Venus and
early Mars tell us that rocky planets
seemed to start out with warm oceans and
organic molecules and the kinds of
environments and physical requirements
that we understand are necessary for the
origin of life so it may be that that
the the conditions for the origin of
life are not all that rare on earth like
planets and what may be more what seems
to be more rare is the persistence of
life that maintaining those conditions
over billions of years for whatever
reason and we're still in search of that
reason something happened on earth that
apparently didn't happen on Mars and
Venus the formation of a robust and
self-sustaining biosphere and we've
learned that life the influence of life
goes very deep on earth you've heard of
the Gaia hypothesis it's not just the
atmosphere but now it turns out the
physical properties of the earth itself
even the interior of the earth earth
earth is a planet that's thoroughly
modified by life and in fact I like this
quote by my colleague Colin Goldblatt at
on the University of Victoria in British
Columbia he said the defining
characteristic of Earth is planetary
scale life and Earth teaches us that
habitability and inhabitants are
inseparable in other words when we go
out looking for habitable planets
elsewhere we can't just look for
physical conditions that would be nice
for life we have to look for a biosphere
in effect a living world like we have
here on earth so it seems as though
early on in its existence earth went
through some kind of a juncture went
down a different path
maybe maybe took the road less traveled
I don't know but but which
differentiated itself and life we didn't
just have an origin of life we have sort
of take over take over of the earth by
life and now we find ourselves at a new
kind of planetary juncture
more recently Earth has come on
the influence of a new kite new type of
geological force the global activities
of humanity defining this Anthropocene
epoch and the question that I am sort of
obsessed by I guess thinking of it in
this context of overall planetary
evolution is is this good intelligence
like life become a planetary property
you know life is something that there
was we had an origin of life on Earth
and then we had life became a robust
self-sustaining property of the earth
now we've had arguably an or an origin
of intelligence on earth although I
think that's debatable but the question
is or one question is when we think
about longevity and and persistence can
this become a planetary property can the
fact that cognitive properties cognitive
processes are now affecting the
evolution of the planet can that become
some kind of a self-sustaining and
robust property of the planet now going
back and planetary history a little bit
I mentioned this briefly but we are not
the first species to come along and
radically change the planet you could
even say that we're not the first
species to come along and in the quest
for a new energy source exploiting that
energy source polluting the atmosphere
profoundly to the point where mass
extinction and climate catastrophe
ensued that's been done before you know
nothing nothing's it's so hard to be
original these days every idea every
idea has been had but so these guys
these little guys the cyanobacteria they
look innocent enough don't they but a
couple billion years ago two and a half
billion years ago they discovered this
new energy source solar energy and
started to the solar started to do
photosynthesis very efficiently whereby
they're breaking up water and co2 and
spitting out the oxygen and make
organic stuff too for metabolism and
that oxygen is a highly toxic gas to
organic matter oxygen reacts violently
with organic matter and this was when it
started to build up in the atmosphere
that was poison and led to extinction of
a lot of species all the species that
couldn't sort of hide in the mud or in
an anaerobic environment were wiped out
now of course that same sounds weird to
us because we love oxygen I know I do
good stuff but that's because we've
evolved the capacity to take advantage
of those violent reactions between
oxygen and organic matter and every cell
of your body there are these little
power plants that that metabolize that
that do a sort of controlled burn of
organics with that oxygen and store up
the energy in these phosphate bonds and
that's that's how we live so before we
evolved that capacity this was
catastrophic not only that but it
probably led to the greatest climate
catastrophe the earth has ever known
there's something called the Paleo
Proterozoic snowball earth where earth
was completely covered in ice and could
have almost led to the extinction of
life on Earth and we think that happened
as a result of this pulse of oxygen
wiping out the methane that at that time
was supporting the greenhouse on earth
and caused a climate crash so not to
belabor this but we're not the first
species to come along and sort of
wrecked the planet but obviously there's
something different going on now what is
that it's another way of getting at this
question of what kind of a planetary
phenomena are we so we're not the first
species to call it cause global change
but clearly we're not we're not bacteria
you know we have some some sense of
responsibility so what exactly have we
got the cyanobacteria didn't and you
know a lot of people have attempted to
address this this question of human
uniqueness and we talk about things like
language
we'll use our technology you know
there's a long history of you know a lot
of that you can find exceptions but
collectively I think we can agree that
these kinds of human qualities including
the sharing of cumulative knowledge over
generations there's clearly something
new going on here and without trying to
put a name on it I'm just going to refer
collectively to the set of human
qualities but this one on the lower
right here responsibility is key that's
what differentiates us of course is that
we can see what we're doing we can see
what's coming and we ought to have some
sense of responsibility but in order to
to get at this question in a slightly
different way of really what's different
about this transition I've looked at all
the major kinds of catastrophic changes
that can happen to planets like ours and
I've tried I've put together a sort of
taxonomy of planetary catastrophes and
I've decided that with respect to the
influence of life oh yeah I forgot about
this slide so so we can ask cumulatively
are these qualities adaptive or an
evolutionary dead end you know we're
very proud of our abilities but we're
not completely convinced that this
experiments going to work here right so
we can ask is this an evolutionary dead
end or some kind of potential gateway to
great longevity if civilization is now a
planetary process what are its prospects
here and elsewhere in the universe so
one way to look at this I've I've put
together this sort of taxonomy of types
of planetary change categorized with
respect to the role of life so what I
call planetary changes of the first kind
are random catastrophes these are
dramatic planetary changes where life
has nothing to do with it you know
you're just in the wrong place at the
wrong time an asteroid hits it's the
canonical example but there are other
examples to the many several mass
extinction
have happened because of these these
dramatic changes in the interior
convective activity of the earth which
lead to this this massive belch of
volcanic activity which causes climate
change and a mass extinction so these
are the changes where life is just an
innocent bystander you know this is when
bad things happen to good planets
planetary changes of the first kind
planetary changes of the second kind or
what I call biological catastrophes and
I symbolize that here by the with the
green leaf because I already mentioned
the cyanobacteria and what happened when
life figured out photosynthesis these
are catastrophes that happen when life
is just doing what life does and
opportunistically evolving finding new
ways to survive multiplying and in the
process changing the environment often
to the detriment of other species and
sometimes leading to a planetary
catastrophe so there are a few other
examples of this that the the the most
dramatic example is the the great
oxygenation catastrophe now the next two
kinds of planetary change this is where
the cognitive processes enter into it
but I want to emphasize that there are
are two different ways that that this
can manifest what I call planetary
changes of the third kind are
inadvertent planetary catastrophes and I
symbolize this here with traffic this is
when a species a very species develops
technology begins to extend its reach
and is very clever at applying this to
solving local survival problems so
clever in fact that they multiply and
spread around their planet and having no
idea at first having no idea they are
doing so begin to cause planetary scale
changes and this leads to what I call
the
whoops the anthropocene dilemma haven't
I'm getting overzealous with my clicking
and I'm gonna there we go
this leads to what I call the
Anthropocene dilemma which is when you
have global influence but not any sense
of global control and it's cognitively
it's on the level of a child who has not
yet developed situational awareness you
know so you're not aware of the effects
that you're having you walk into a room
and you smash things over and you know
it's the bullying that in the china shop
and it's it's unstable it's dangerous so
and it's symbolized by traffic here
because you look at this picture and
each one of these cars is being driven
by a person with agency and they can do
a fine job of seeing obstacles coming
and steering around them hitting the
brake when they need to works just fine
but if you look at the system as a whole
you can ask well who's driving the
global transportation system and the
answer is kind of well nobody so we're
participating in it but we're not
controlling it and when we talk about a
lot of global processes you know we talk
about the market or we talk about other
the other phenomena that we participate
in but not necessarily fully control
it's often as though we're describing
something external to ourselves and yet
we participate in it so this is what I
mean by by the inadvertent kind of
planetary change in examples of this the
obvious example on the left here is the
the Keeling curve that you know about
the dramatic rise in carbon dioxide
through industrial activity and this
slide is a little bit updated system and
a 95 ppm now it's over 400 I mean if
they keep updating this slide when you
give talks about this and all of the the
phenomena this results in and I don't
need to for this audience talk at length
about this obviously that change in co2
and that this is this marvelous
animation I got from the Cowell Academy
showing the sources and sinks of co2
over a year and there's actually a lot
there that you can see the induct the
co2 sort of emerging from the industrial
dense industrial areas and actually
being taken up by the forested areas so
it's pretty cool and over on the right
the sort of frightening decline of the
sea ice and this is the most concerning
but not the only of these inadvertent
kinds of changes that are going on now
this is of course the famous ozone hole
which is also something you know about
and you can see starting in the 1970s we
discovered this and by the way we
discovered this in part because we were
exploring the planet Venus and some
science some of my colleagues were
trying to figure out a puzzle in the
upper atmosphere of Venus why there was
not enough oxygen there you know there
Venus is mostly co2 so it's a great
example of the greenhouse effect gone
wild and there's a question of in the
upper atmosphere there should be about
of oxygen because co2 is being broken up
by ultraviolet light but the oxygen
molecules are missing so people were
trying to solve this and some scientists
said well there's these experiments I
saw on this lab over here that shows
that chlorine destroys oxygen compounds
it you know in the right situation I
wonder if that could be going on and
they did some more observations and
found chlorine it said aha and then some
other scientists read that paper and
said oh well what about all this
chlorine we're putting up in Earth's
stratosphere with these new miracle safe
refrigerants CFCs and they saw that and
they went oh wait a minute and sort of
put two and two together and sounded the
alarm and then you can see the ozone
hole deepens here through the 1980s but
then it starts to level off because even
though this is definitely a classic
example of an inadvertent global
catastrophe which unchecked could have
truly been catastrophic it's also my
first example of what I call the Fourth
Kind of planetary change which is
intentional intentional change because
the story of the ozone is that when the
scientist sounded the alarm
there was a global discussion one might
say he did global argument about what to
do about it
and there was denial there was
professionally supported denial where
experts were hired by the companies that
manufactured these things to muddy the
waters and put out what we might today
call fake science disputing this a lot
of the dynamics we see in play now with
our problems with with fossil fuels and
climate played out but what happened in
this case was that global agreements
were made actually what happened was the
ozone halt started opening up over
Antarctica and that scared people it
even scared the directors of the DuPont
corporation and they decided okay let's
do something about this global
agreements were made treaties were
signed there was the the Montreal
Protocol for the regulation of ozone
destroying substances or whatever it's
called and and you know it wasn't just
that the the companies suddenly became
fully altruistic they also saw there was
money to be made in there making the
replacement refrigerants that would be
necessary and then they ran out and got
the patents for those but however it
played out it's a success story in that
we saw this problem coming and we worked
out a global solution and the ozone hole
is now on track to being fixed it's not
fully fixed yet because it takes about
50 years for these chemical reactions to
to reconstitute the ozone but it's
definitely I think an important example
a proof of concept that there is another
way that we are capable of another way
of responding to a self-induced
planetary emergency now moving on to
other examples of this fourth kind of
planetary change intentional change
obviously our most urgent need now is to
transform our energy sources into ones
that are not wrecking the natural
systems that we and the creatures we
share this planet with depend upon just
five and that's symbolized in the upper
right here and that is a transition that
is in progress and we're all I think
those of us paying attention are
frustrated by the pace of that
transition but it is occurring there's
no doubt in my mind 100 years from now
we will not have a fossil fuel based
economy we will get from here to there
it's a question of the pace and how much
damage will do along the way I believe
100 years from now we'll be repairing
some of that damage but at any rate as
far as intentional changes to the planet
that is obviously our most urgent
challenge but it doesn't end there when
we think farther into the future and we
start to conceive of ourselves in this
role of possibly intervening in the
planet then we start to realize other
responsibilities and I described them as
responsibilities because once there's an
intervention that we we realize we could
take that would save many many species
would possibly prevent a mass extinction
then we sort of become obligated to
attempt to make that intervention so
looking at the rest of this slide here
I've got on the bottom left I've got the
possibility of dangerous asteroid
impacts and on the bottom right I've got
the possibility of future dangerous
quote natural climate changes which left
to their own devices would on a longer
time scale lead to some very dangerous
behavior on this planet let me expand
upon that just a little bit this is
actually data each one of these little
insect like objects in this swarm each
one of these is a known earth-crossing
asteroid these are all objects that
could hit the earth in the future now
this is really sped up so don't
don't lose sleep over this if there's
something you want to lose sleep over I
can give you a another suggestion but
but the point is that this is a very
real almost actually inevitable threat
if you go out on a long enough time
scale that there will be asteroids that
can hit the planet but the good news is
we actually know how to do something
about this
it's a tractable problem given enough
time and we chances are we would have a
lot of time because what we're doing now
is observing these objects and if we had
a decade or a hundred years which we
probably would to see something coming
it's not that hard to go out and give
something a little nudge
so knowing about this then I think it
sort of becomes our obligation to
develop that capability and I actually
think this is what I call the big
payback I think in the long run it's
quite possible that we could prevent a
lot more extinction than we're causing
now we could prevent the next mass
extinction and I mentioned intentional
climate change we think of climate is
something we often think of climate is
something that left to its own devices
is friendly and benign and off we would
just be hands off and let the you know
the earth is a paradise left left to
itself well it will take care that of
course is an illusion an illusion
because we've come along at an unusual
time of Earth history our civilization
if you can call it that has sprung up in
this 10,000 year period of relatively
warm and stable climate but of course
you go out to tens of thousands of years
and that's no longer true there's this
Milankovitch cycle the ice age cycle and
we do not want to try to live through
another Ice Age our civilization would
not survive that the North America was
covered with a a mile thick sheet of ice
in the last ice age but it wouldn't be
that hard to prevent if we if we're
around 10,000 50,000 years from now I
think will easily know enough to prevent
that but we have to be comfortable in
that role of thinking ourselves as not
trying to just sort of avoid messing up
the earth that's our first task is
to get over this phase of sort of
climate vandalism that were adolescent
climate vandalism that were perpetrating
right now but but it doesn't end there
the more mature phase is realizing that
we have the possibility of intervening
on behalf of life in the longer run and
you know see if you want to get nerdy
about it we can sum up some of these
planetary changes of the Fourth Kind in
terms of different time scales and on
the y-axis here I have sort of where we
are the very top
our global problems that we've solved
and I have the smallpox vaccine as an
example of there and the ozone is a
problem that we we're at least on track
and that's you know both of those are
probably I put in a this is log year so
those are like 100 year timescales
on about a thousand year timescale we
really have to be serious about
planetary defense
I got Mars terraforming in there it's
something we could talk about if if you
want it I put it in there because it's
another example of intentional
intervention in planetary evolution as
opposed to sort of inadvertent or random
when you get up to about ten thousand
year arm sorry hundred thousand year
timescales then you really have to worry
about ice ages and whether we want to
intervene in them and then if you go all
the way to the the right hand side here
eventually if there's anybody still here
we or our descendants or our creations
or the descendants of our creations or
somebody else completely who came along
the point is somebody's going to have to
deal with the fact that the Sun is
actually not a fully renewable energy
source if you if you go to a billion
year timescale so the Sun will run out
of fuel and consume the earth but I
maintain if anybody's around for that
long then that will also be a tractable
problem probably because they'll just be
able to to move but so coming back to
earth for a second the the Anthropocene
there's a lot of talk and debate about
when it one of the things people love to
do
when it started I'm not that interested
in that debate I mean they're all
interesting ideas is that the nuclear
bomb isotope horizon is that the in the
when when the Industrial Revolution the
steam engine and we started putting co2
in the atmosphere
some people say was 8,000 years ago and
we started large-scale agriculture and
changed the land in the climate it
doesn't really matter to me when we say
it started the more interesting question
to me is when will it end
or will it end or what really is it in
Earth history is it an event like the
cretaceous-tertiary boundary you know
where that when the asteroid hit there's
a centimeter thick layer of clay all
around the earth where the detritus from
that asteroid hit that's an event in
Earth history or is it something more
sustained like it's often called an
epoch epochs tend to last ten million
years or so fifteen million years or is
it actually something different a
planetary transition like the origin of
life or the Cambrian explosion as I
mentioned at the beginning that our
planets have been through a few of these
transitions where it was a completely
different planet before and after and in
my view that's what we have to shoot for
we have to imagine that now that we're
here and we realize we can play a role
on this planet we have to choose a
constructive role rather than a
destructive role and part of that
choosing a constructive role is in
imagining ourselves on a long time scale
and thinking what would it be what would
it mean for this cognitive process to
actually become a sustained part of
planetary functioning now when we get to
these thoughts of very long timescales
we often intersect with some of the ways
that people are thinking in the field of
SETI the search for extraterrestrial
intelligence if you look at the
literature of SETI even going back to
the 1960s when people first started
seriously you know Frank Drake and his
colleagues started seriously
listening and thinking about what it
would take to make contact with
extraterrestrials the people doing the
theory of said he quickly realized that
the crucial question was all about
longevity longevity of civilizations you
can do the math you've probably seen the
Drake Equation with all these different
parameters for how many planets there
are what fraction of them have life what
fraction of them there's that but they
the crucial thing is how long disavows
Asians last if civilizations all do
themselves in within a hundred or a
thousand years then you can do the math
and show there's going to be nobody you
can talk to because the average distance
to the not not that there's nobody there
but the average distance to the nearest
civilization will be so long that the
chance of you and them being alive at
the same time and able to communicate is
basically zero on the other hand if
civilizations even a small fraction of
them can last a long time say thousands
tens of thousands hundreds of thousands
millions of years even longer then it's
quite likely that there would be one
nearby enough to communicate with so
it's all about longevity and when I
think about this question of this
transition that Earth is undergoing now
and try to abstract it so it's not just
about humanity and what we're doing here
but a kind of thing that can happen to a
planet where life evolves to a point
where cognitive processes start to
become planetary processes and I wonder
if that might be happening elsewhere in
the cosmos it's just another way to sort
of abstract what's going on here and
that went and then I realize that the
central problem of study is really the
same as the central problem that we are
facing now as a civilization as a
species on earth which is is it possible
to develop a mature long term healthy
relationship with world-changing
technology I think it is and I don't
want to go on at length about why that
is because I want to
to wrap up here so we can get to the
discussion part but let me just make a
couple of points it's very clear to me
that in order for our civilization to
survive we do need to become a new kind
of entity on this planet and learn to
live comfortably over the long haul with
world changing technology and this is
something that in my in my book I call
this terra sapiens the need to become
terra sapiens which of course sapiens
means wise and when Linnaeus named us he
was looking for a phrase that would
differentiate us from the other hominid
species and he called us Homo sapiens
wise Apes maybe that was a little bit of
overreach or wishful thinking and yet I
find it useful as a as an aspirational
name for this this this epoch that we
may be developing now people say that's
impossible they say look at our behavior
on earth now how could you even imagine
we can do that but I say let's look at
our deep history not just our history of
the last few decades or hundreds or even
thousands of years but our history as a
species and one thing you learn when you
look at our deep history of species the
deep history of our species is that we
are unique in our capacity for self
reinvention and in times of existential
threat we have completely reinvented
ourselves before and often it's
interesting if you look at the history
of our ancestors in Africa pre humans in
Africa it's often in response to climate
change that we've invented and refined
new capacities for survival this map
here on the left this is a place called
pinnacle point near the southern tip of
Africa and it's the place where a lot of
anthropologists now think that the
origin of modern humans may have taken
place there's an archaeological site
there where it seems as though these
were the survivors when the human race
are
or the pre humans almost went extinct
about a hundred ninety thousand years
ago there was a genetic bottleneck and
we were almost completely wiped out down
to probably fewer than a thousand
individuals and this may be where we
made our stand pinnacle point and we had
to learn a completely different way of
surviving because up to that point we
were hunter-gatherers but there was an
ice age in Africa at that time and we
couldn't hunt the way we were used to
because the game died out because
because it was because of climate change
there was nothing to hunt and the people
at pinnacle point found ways to hunt for
shellfish and they invented new
technologies and this is the origin of
what is called long-chain complex recipe
technology and what that means is these
are technologies where you have to go
through some complex set of steps to
produce something like smelting of
metals or heat treatment of rocks so
that the the product that you're getting
is not obvious from the ingredients you
start with their steps are are its
long-chain complex recipe technology and
it requires new levels of language and
cooperation and you have to be able to
teach it to the next generation and
they're also there's art here and
evidence of pigments and personal
adornment so this may be where we became
human it may not be but the point is
there are many examples like this we're
faced with catastrophe we reinvented
ourselves and reinvented ourselves in
ways that required cooperation and
invention on larger scales and that's
what we humans are good at and when
people tell me there's no way we're
going to harness ourselves and create
this society where we actually are able
to use our technology as a mostly as a
survival tool rather than a to threaten
ourselves
I asked them imagine trying to describe
a modern city to the people of pinnacle
point and the way we live now it we very
hard
and maybe that's just as hard as it is
for us to imagine Tara sapiens the
reinvention that we are perhaps
beginning now so when I talk about the
safety as oeq eon obviously it's
aspirational the thing is in order for
something for a period of time a
geological period of geological time to
be an eon it has to persist not just for
thousands not just for millions of years
but for billions of years so we can't
possibly know if it's an eon we won't
know it for millions of years and yet to
me that's the way to think of this is
that we're in it for the long haul like
it or not we are now planetary players I
don't believe we have the option to note
to stop being a geological force so we
needed to learn how to be a good one how
to be a constructive one and one last
point the metaphors we use to describe
ourselves are so often negative and
destructive we're a cancer on this earth
were criminals
we're raping the rainforest now I
understand the origin of those metaphors
you look at a lot of our behavior and
it's reprehensible you know there are
human development does tend to have a
cancer like property when seen from the
air and you know when I hear about the
the white rhinos of Africa going extinct
at our hand you know it's unforgivable
it is a crime and yet there's something
different here because the cancer
doesn't stop and have a conversation
with other cancer cells and go hey you
know maybe we shouldn't be a cancer
because because if this person dies then
then we're gonna die too you know so
there are my point is that these
metaphors describe a certain component
of our path but they don't have to
describe our future I think we can find
other metaphors the there's the metaphor
of youth of just waking up to find out
what we are here on this world there's
the metaphor of the the unschooled
driver where we're driving down the road
and we suddenly realized oh I'm driving
this big rig and everybody I love and
everything I care abouts in the back but
I don't actually know how to drive I
better learn in a hurry to me that's our
situation on earth or theirs on the
right here there's the metaphor of the
sleepwalker you know I'm sort of waking
up to find ourselves in the middle of of
committing these crimes and saying oh
wow what are we doing here and then
finally the maybe you're familiar with
the the trope of science fiction the
generation ship story of the most famous
of which is orphans of the sky by Robert
Heinlein this comes from the idea that
if people are ever going to travel
between the stars to other star systems
the distances are too far using any
technology we can imagine for people to
go within a human lifetime so how do we
get to the Stars one way is to build
these generation ships where the people
who arrive are the descendants multiple
generations later of the people who set
out and there's a lot of good good
stories about this and in those stories
something always goes wrong you know
there's been a mutiny or a revolution or
some kind of breakdown and the people on
that ship don't realize that they're on
a generation ship anymore they think
this is just the world and then our
protagonists are heroes they figure it
out
and they go oh wow you know they find a
porthole and they look out and they see
the Stars or they find the control room
and they go wow we're on a ship we're
going somewhere we have to wake
everybody up and and and tell them to
you know what's going on see our reality
and to me that's that's sort of where we
are on this planet right now is that you
know we are realizing the nature of our
existence on this planet and we just
kind of have to wake everybody up so
that we can do a better job of driving
this thing you've probably seen this I
want to I want to end with this lovely
cartoon by R crumb and from a local
publication of some ill repute and
this is and and mr. Krum very generously
gave me permission to use this artwork
in my book which I was very pleased by
and this is his a brief history of
America and you can see it starts off
with this pastoral scene in the upper
left and it's the same scene every
decade and very slowly the influence of
modern you know technological society
creeps in and it's still quite pastoral
for the first few friends then of course
by the bottom right we've you know with
even though every step is gradual we've
come to this rather completely urbanized
landscape where there's no no trees and
the sky's got a sort of unhealthy pallor
and then at the but I don't think you
can see it but on the bottom right there
is little listless little thing he says
what's next and that's where it ends he
wrote he did this in 1979 but sometime I
think about a decade later he was asked
to if he would do a sequel in epilogue
and he did three more panels showing the
future three possible futures the top
one is worst case scenario ecological
disaster not too much to be said about
that of them that's what we want to
avoid but then the bottom two are very
different the middle one says the fun
future techno fix on the March and
there's people in flying cars and
everything's all sort of regimented but
but very nice and there are trees but
they're planted in nice you know
controlled rows and then the bottom one
is the e-coat opium solution and you
know you can see people are living in
tree houses and playing acoustic
instruments and riding riding bicycles
and these two bottom frames to me
symbolize in a sort of cartoon way this
debate that's going on now about our
future between the the the eco
pragmatists the eco pragmatists and the
traditional sort of reactionary
conservationists and you know in in a
cartoon sense the eco pragmatist want
this techno fix on the march and the the
traditional conservationists want the
e-coat opium solution and in my view
they're sort of both right that the
future is going to need some combination
we need innovation
which is really this middle panel and we
also need restraint which is this this
lower panel but I think some some wise
combination of these two bottom
philosophies will lead us into the 22nd
23rd century in a way that will avoid
the ecological disaster scenario so
that's it I want to end with a with a
quote from one of my heroes dr. Martin
Luther King jr. if we are to have peace
on earth which I interpret also to mean
if we're to build a sustainable global
civilization then our loyalties must
transcend our differences and we must
develop a world perspective and on that
I will stop so thank you very much
[Music]
Hilda Bay lost now I've got sound and
now I'll probably destroy it I'm gonna
show you a photograph first I'll show it
to everybody else the photograph I took
in July 1976 and it's a JPL Jet
Propulsion Laboratory in Pasadena and
we're looking at coming down on a
computer screen what was the very first
images from the Viking Lander and I'll
ask if you recognize the character that
the glasses is looking at it I
absolutely do that to Uncle Carl yeah
Carl Sagan those Viking landers Viking
landings were seminal events in my
teenage life and yeah that's that's
Uncle Carl looking at a one of the first
scenes from the Viking one land or on
Mars which is our first Lander yeah
they're amazing later than that day you
saw these images building and it's
interesting because they came in really
mucky and then the computer algorithms
cut in and started to make sense of the
grays and the whites and the blacks made
a motor nice to see that you were
looking at the foot of the lander and
Martian landscape behind it and of
course Carl was there and Bradbury was
there Heinlein was there are various
people there I was there because
Governor Brown was there and I was part
of his entourage and Carl of course was
set up with a Mach set up both of the
lander and there's television network
sir over there of course talking to Carl
Sagan so all right what do you think is
there life on Mars and he says big grin
there is no I love it yeah I remember
that day it was made a big impression on
me yeah
well it's funny I did grow up calling
him Uncle Carl because he he was a he
and my dad were best friends when I was
at when I
kid and he was a big inspiration they
were both Harvard professors at that
time that was before Carl got kicked out
of Harvard for political activities and
ended up it at Cornell but well he was
denied tenure and you know there's no
official reason but he was the student
he was the faculty advisor for the SDS
and there's a lot of speculation that
that was why but any rate so so I grew
up with him around the house a lot and
you know telling bedtime stories and
stuff and showing up with with pictures
of planets and very very inspirational
figure in my life and then later on I we
ended up collaborating on some
scientific studies of climate on early
Earth so sort of went full cycle in that
way I remember a lot of scientists
basically peeing all over Carl Sagan for
being so popular and so engaged yes
stuff it was easy to mock but he did a
lot of serious science he did some
serious art like with the book contact
which became a good movie contact and I
think he's set in motion for your
generation a sense of responsibility to
be more transparent more communicative
about the science that one was doing is
that he says absolutely no I mean Arnold
got a lot of crap from the scientific
community and a lot of it was because
people said he was just a popularizer
like that was like something wrong to be
speaking with to the masses you know
it's like Galileo got in trouble for
writing an Italian write rather than
them Latin it's there's a long tradition
of people getting in trouble for using
the people's language but he was given a
fair amount of crap and you know some
people thought it was jealousy and maybe
it was because he was the one on Johnny
Carson you know but it was not seen as a
fully respectable thing for scientists
to do but now I think people realize as
you say much more that it's the
obligation and in fact a pleasure of
being a scientist is to go out and
communicate
people what's the point of doing it if
you can't talk about it especially since
it's mostly public funded so he was a
trailblazer in that way he also didn't
shy away from controversy with nuclear
winter and you know he got into some
territory that that pissed off the
powers that be a little bit as well so
that was probably part of it you know he
didn't always choose the easy path to
questions about ice ages Tim what
session we invoke a small ice age to
avoid sea level rise problems it's one
of the old-fashioned ways that sea
levels are kept from rising is more ice
and Deborah says in terms of possibility
of intentionally controlling climate
starting off with an ice age what's the
human responsibility for other life
forms addition to our own life form I
mean ice ages turn a whole lot of living
landscape into pretty nonliving ice so
yeah two good questions I mean first of
all you know we don't really want to
invoke an ice age because there's self
accelerating yeah that it you know they
can lead to instability a little ice age
can become a big ice age but also I mean
that's like what we I think what we want
to go for is something like what the
climates been like the last 10,000 years
which is it's actually been an
interglacial as what we call that a
little warm period in the middle of a
larger period basically what we're in
the middle of an ice age but we're in
this interglacial which is sort of a
falling within the ice age but the idea
of trying to restore some of the ice
that we're now losing and dissipating in
the around the Arctic is an interesting
idea and I have heard some proposals of
you know the people have for these sort
of solar-powered ice makers that we
would you know I I'm not I'm not ready
to go there yet but I think I'm all in
favor of people researching that I think
that we we still haven't tried the
obvious which is just limiting our co2
emissions by
you know by changing our energy supply
but I think you know in terms of these
more radical geoengineering schemes I'm
definitely in favor of people doing the
research and knowing what our options
are in case we need them but I think
it's foolish to jump into tinkering
where you know you don't want the Cure
to be worse than the disease we have to
know what we're doing we've got a lot to
learn before we try some of these more
radical interventions as far as our
responsibility to other creatures that's
an interesting one I mean you know
there's there's the pragmatic issue that
we don't want to cause want an
extinction even for our own
self-interest because we need other
species we need a healthy biosphere for
just for agriculture for biomedicine for
all these reasons we don't want to live
on a planet you know and then of course
there's the ethical and moral question
of you know since we're conscious and
aware of our role at least to some
degree
you know then we you know do we want to
be the species that causes a mass
extinction and so to me the ethical and
the pragmatic kind of merged there where
it's clearly in our interest both so we
can live with ourselves and so we can
live well to to safeguard the diversity
of life on Earth as well as safeguard
our own our own future I think the two
goals really converge a couple questions
here that relate to something which when
you said you know civilizations managed
longevity can they do tens of thousands
of years hundreds of thousands of years
the mind starts to go oh wait a minute
because Chloe yes the question change it
seems to be speeding up what does that
look like in terms of this long very
long term scale longevity and Shawn
asked by the way in terms of planetary
intelligence can the proliferation of
artificial intelligence be the beginning
of planetary intelligence artificial
intelligence is one of the modes of
speeding up of world-changing technology
that we're talking about so artificial
intelligence at planetary scale
and pace of change yeah well that either
those lead to longevity
well that's it's a great question and
you know I think with artificial
intelligence the honest answer about
that is nobody knows where it's going a
lot of people a lot of really smart
people have a lot of interesting ideas
about where that's going
I think it's legitimately considered to
be likely almost inevitably to be a
game-changer in the 21st century and the
game changers are frightening but they
can also be you know wonderful things I
personally am NOT a believer in the the
singularity the moment of you know sort
of techno rapture I shouldn't say that
here somebody might offend someone yes
well no I mean it's it's possible it's
and it's quite possible I say I'm not a
believe that's a little too strong I
think that I think that it depends on a
certain model of what the brain is and
what how what consciousness is and its
relationship to the brain where you're
just going to create a certain number of
very fast processors in network with
each other and then you'll basically
have a brain and then the brain will
even be better than our brains that's
possible but it depends on on a lot on a
certain model of of what a brain really
is that we are what consciousness really
is that we I would say is unverified but
what I do think is equally possible is
that that our human and and is already
happening is that our human networks
will become much better and much smarter
in augmented and in partnership with the
networked smart machines and could
actually potentially become that sort of
missing link in our ability to globally
have some coordination in on the scales
and in the ways that we need to to sort
of manage ourselves smartly so I see it
as equally probable that that sort of a
partnership of humans and machines could
become that sustainable entity I think
in terms of evolution you know you think
of endosymbiosis the forming of
organisms by a partnerships of smaller
organisms and the fact that we of course
you can look at yourself we are
collections of bacteria not just both
because of our microbiome and because
our cells themselves are collections of
bacterial cells and they are still
within us doing what bacteria do and I
think being pretty happy I could see us
with the aid of these machines
essentially becoming
netware i'm not talking about the matrix
necessarily oh the Borg although maybe I
am but maybe I am but but they coming
you know continuing to function and feel
like humans doing what we're doing but
embedded within some matrix of smart
machines that are kind of taking care of
things in the way we need them taken
care of
so it's a very hard question to answer
because it's one of these things that
seems clearly to be accelerating and to
be a likely game changer and I've heard
a lot of really smart predictions of
what it's going to lead to I you know I
read these books by Max tegmark and by
God what's his name the guy this much
more pessimistic Nick Bostrom thank you
yeah and and I read this and I go yep
you could very well be right but am I
convinced that you really know nope and
that's basically my reaction to all of
these so well I'm intrigued by your
bringing up through the microbial
perspective you sounds like somebody was
bitten early age absolutely yeah yep
another another big influence yep
yeah and Lynn was a brilliant scientist
and she was right about a lot of things
before before and then she was right
again but the inner should be are they
that these various creatures that were
basically enemies or eating each other
got inside each other and
became collaboratively much more
powerful so we have mitochondria in
every one of our cells that have their
own DNA because they used to be another
species and she was the great proponent
of that and realize er that and every
time I hung out with when I would get a
sense that microbes
swapping genes all that time doing all
that's you know they're doing the
figuring out quorum and then acting on
the koalas and making biofilms and the
the intensity of the interaction that
microbes have we have yet to get you
right but what you were just describing
it sounds like we are in the path to
getting into that level of interaction
well I wonder I wonder if that's partly
that that's sort of my I think I'm I've
admitted I'm sort of a congenital
optimist so I always search for the the
the pasta the way in which things could
actually be working out to our favor and
that I am drawn to that analogy that we
are as yet like a very crude assemblage
of microbes that haven't really figured
out how to do endosymbiosis yet but but
the the sort of connective tissue that
we need could be our our smartmachine
networks there's a transition going on
right now from basically accelerating
power and power of digital code to now
include the accelerating power and power
of of genetic code and your biologists
and astrobiologist we're still a
biologist what do you make of all that
well I think it's very exciting I mean
it's it's another one I think it's a
little bit daunting because it's so
powerful and who knows what it could
lead to but but it's it's kind of funny
that that in our
attempt to come up with better and
better digital storage and more and more
efficient ways of encoding information
that you know TS Eliot said at the end
of all our exploring we come back you
know to the place we started and see it
as if that we end up with afterthought
is like Oh DNA that's not what should
store information you know sort of like
DNA gave us these brains to develop all
this digital technology and made us
smart enough to like come back and go
WOW DNA is really good story so some it
is very intriguing that that that
ultimately by hacking biology we may
empower ourselves more than just by
invent inventing a related question
which hacking digital code doesn't seem
to bother anybody
hacking biological code seems to bother
almost everybody what's that's an
interesting question too maybe because
the monsters that we can imagine are
scarier than the monsters we can't
imagine
it's pretty good right you're gonna you
can imagine all kinds of like scary
variations of biological creatures we
have no idea what a machine monster
would even you know be like so but
you're right I mean it's it maybe it's
kind of prejudice we have given our
current tools what are our best
techniques to detect bio related epic
changes in extrasolar planets and by the
way how about sapien yeah yeah okay so
our best I mean there's a couple
problems one is just you know even if we
knew what to look for on exoplanets how
do we detect it because they're so darn
far away and you know getting any
information I mean just the fact that
we've been able to determine that
they're there is a huge breakthrough and
a lot of times that we can't even see
them we detect them indirectly because
we see the wobble that they're moving a
star around or something so learning
anything about exoplanets is going to be
very hard however there's a new
generation of instruments and a new
generation of scientists a lot of the
people working on exoplanets now are
young really clever astronomers who are
figuring out way I thought when it when
we first detected exoplanets I thought
well we're never going to know much
about them and of course now people are
applying themselves and they're finding
very clever ways by looking at the light
from That star when it passes through
the planet that's transiting in front of
it and how you know you can say
something about what's in that
atmosphere they're starting to figure it
out so then the question is okay but
what do we actually look for to find
life and a lot of it goes back to Jim
Lovelock and Lynn Margulis actually in
the idea that life creates
disequilibrium you know you don't want
to be too geocentric and say we want to
look just for oxygen or just for
carbon-based life because then what if
it's doing something different but the
idea of looking for equilibrium that
whatever life is however life works
elsewhere it's going to create some
chemical disturbance it's going to use
energy and change the chemical balance
of its environment so if you just look
for
weird atmospheric chemistry for
chemistry that wouldn't be there without
some something provoking it then that
something could be life so that's sort
of our main technique now is to just
start determining the atmospheric
composition of exoplanets and look for
mixtures of gases that seem to be not
natural in the sense of not geological
and then so what's weird what's yeah
that's if if you were astrobiologists
and some other star system and you had a
good enough spectrometer so you could
look at the atmospheres of the planets
in our solar system you'd look at Mars
and you're going a lot of co2 that's
kind of normal for a rocky planet you
look at Venus you go about a co2 that's
kind of normal for rocky planet you look
at Earth and you'd go whoa check this
out you'd call your buddy over you'd hit
them with your on the back with your
tentacle and go you know it's earth is
flagrantly strange its atmosphere all
this oxygen and not just oxygen about
oxygen mixed with methane those are
gases that eat each other they don't
coexist unless something is violently
forcing them into the atmosphere and in
fact if all the life on Earth died out
it would quickly revert to a Venus or
Mars like state and would just be co2
and so Earth's atmospheres flagrantly
disturbed yeah yeah so then it was
probably more subtle the signs of life
but there there was probably an excess
of methane he had methanogenic bacteria
and right well Titan might have life we
can't roll that out yet Titan I mean
that's one of the things that uh that is
to me is intriguing about Titan is why
does it have all that methane it
shouldn't so I'm being a little bit
heretical here but we have not yet
explored time
that chair last month that Titan is just
too cold to 300 degrees Fahrenheit below
zero for life processes for metabolism
basically to have much of a chance well
Carolyn no no I mean of course this is
these these are the kinds of things that
that astrobiologists wrestle with what
are really the requirements can we say
that life needs a temperature range like
we enjoy or is that just are we just
being self-centered obviously our kind
of chemistry would not work on the in
the temperature range of Titan but there
are other kinds of chemistry that that
work well in in those temperatures so I
think we have to be a little careful
before we start declaring places
off-limits to me the only place that you
can declare off limits is a place where
nothing's happening
there's no energy there's no chemical
flow there's no physical flow life needs
some kind of flow some kind of
disequilibrium some kind of exchange of
matter and energy to sort of surf on and
right and and thrive off of so places
where nothing's happening to me are
pretty securely dead so Titan has an
atmosphere and in fact you were
describing before the show of it would
be a great place to develop wings for
people because there's very little
gravity and very thick atmosphere
ringing yeah
human powered flight on the other hand
it has an atmosphere in gym Lovelock
mode you look at the atmospheres or
anything weird about it
well yes because that there there is an
excess of methane on Titan that actually
should go away in like a 10 million ER
time scale because there's ultraviolet
light and particles from Saturn's
magnetosphere that are eating methane on
Titan and we don't know what's
replenishing it now the standard wisdom
is there's some it's cryovolcanoes and
it's coming from the interior and there
it could be but if you're gonna look at
it from a loved Lockean perspective you
could also say hmm maybe we should just
like make sure there's nothing else
going on on Titan because that methane
is a little weird okay so here's your
question
on so we're looking for the biological
epoch transition
and other planets how about the sapiens
transition can you detect that from the
atmosphere
yeah planet yeah so how would you find
identify another planet that had gone
through a safe it was in its apos oh
that's a really good question some
people have said well let's look for you
know carbon dioxide pollution but I
think that's a really bad idea because
that's obviously gonna be a temporary
problem that's not you you know you want
to look for some long-lived signatures
some sign of a stable those are those
are the ones you're gonna find are the
ones that have some lifetime so what I
would look for is the signs of a planet
being managed somehow a climate that is
not being left to its own devices for
instance you know it as we spoke about
if we're going to be here for another
100,000 years we probably would mess
with the cycle of ice ages so how would
we do that one way is by introducing
chemicals like CFCs into the atmosphere
not CFCs themselves because they destroy
ozone but there are other artificial
atmospheric gases that are very powerful
greenhouse gases so if you see some
synthetic gas that seems to not be
natural that's affecting the planet's
climate you see the spectrum of
something like that you go hmm or in a
more general sense over the very long
run stars heat up and the habitable zone
moves out so if you see a planet that
looks as though it has a climate that is
preserved from an earlier epoch in that
solar system's history you might go Oh
somebody's been kind of like messing
with that planet's climate so III don't
want to try to second-guess the aliens
too much because they you know I just
think but I think that as we look for
bio signatures which is what we're
starting to do we should also be on the
lookout for techno signatures if we
start to see weird atmospheres we should
at least consider that as one of the
causal agents
how weird can life get I've been pretty
weird that's a great question yeah
extremophiles that's a great question
you know because as astrobiologists
there's we have this sort of nested set
of assumptions that we make and we
really don't know how good any of them
are we often assume that life needs
carbon and water now maybe it does
because that's certainly a good way of
doing it and people haven't imagined
fully other ways of doing it but maybe
that's just looking for our keys under
the lamppost you know searching
searching for what we under the light
you know searching for what we know and
maybe the reason why nobody's imagined
another you know fully realized system
of biology is because our imaginations
aren't good enough Nature has a way of
solving problems that you know we we
tend to learn things through exploration
not through imagination this is true
when we when we explore the solar system
we didn't think there were going to be
volcanoes on Io until we got there in
fact we knew why there couldn't be and
then once that's right
and when we get there we figure out why
what we knew couldn't be there it could
be there we come up you know so I
suspect it much it'd be much the same
with life so so we assume it has to be
carbon-based maybe it doesn't we assume
it has to be chemical maybe it doesn't
even have to be chemical maybe in a more
general sense any kind of physical
process can create on some scale
self-perpetuating
structures so we really don't know how
weird life can get my my hunch is that
there are at least other chemical
systems for life that have nothing to do
with carbon Freeman Dyson imagines that
you know we assume that rocky planets
are the only place that life can be but
there's a whole lot of different kinds
of environment in space absolutely well
Carl Sagan used to talk about a Carl
Sagan used to talk imagine this whole
ecology on Jupiter of the floaters and
the sink
gasbags and you know i in my view any
place where there's interesting
chemistry and by interesting I mean
flows of you know disequilibrium
chemicals that can react together and
produce energy which then can produce
structures is a possible habitat and I I
think that as we explore further will
will will be surprised just as we've
been in with the geology you know we
just got to Pluto we as we as far as we
knew ya know Pluto's its a great example
of how when we explore our
preconceptions are busted because it's
so far from the Sun there's no energy
source to drive geology and what fooled
us with the moons of the outer solar
system we thought well there can't be
geology on these cold icy balls but they
were because it's all tidal you know the
moons of Jupiter getting pulled around
in Jupiter's gravitational field and
interacting with one another and that
creates these tidal energy sources but
Pluto doesn't have anything like that it
has a moon but there's no tidal
interaction like that but we get to
Pluto and it's full of interesting
geology and glaciers that are flowing
and surfaces that are young and changing
and it's because it's doing it with
other kinds of materials and we didn't
imagine there you know nitrogen here on
earth as a gas we're breathing it right
now and it's this but this is mostly
nitrogen then this air that we're in on
Pluto nitrogen is a solid and there are
glaciers of nitrogen flowing down
mountains of solid water ice so and at
that temperature nitrogen is actually
kind of squishy and volatile and it
doesn't take much to move it around and
it's it's convecting it's you know with
a little meager amount of energy coming
from the radioactive decay of the rocks
inside Pluto it's causing nitrogen
convection and glaciers to flow so this
is all by way of saying they you know
every time we expect a place to be
uninteresting it's because it's our
perspective of not being a little mad
what nature is doing out there that's
true about geology now if I had to guess
it will also be true of biology
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]